welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today my
guest is Dr Eric Jarvis Dr Jarvis is a
professor at the Rockefeller University
in New York City and his laboratory
studies the neurobiology of vocal
learning language speech disorders and
remarkably the relationship between
language music and movement in
particular dance his work spans from
genomics so the very genes that make up
our genome and the genomes of other
species that speak and have language
such as songbirds and parrots all the
way up to neural circuits that is the
connections in the brain and body that
govern our ability to learn and generate
specific sounds and movements
coordinated with those sounds including
hand movements and all the way up to
cognition that is our ability to think
in specific ways based on what we are
saying and the way that we comprehend
what other people are saying singing and
doing
as you'll soon see I was immediately
transfixed and absolutely Enchanted by
Dr Jarvis's description of his work and
the ways that it impacts all the various
aspects of Our Lives for instance I
learned from Dr Jarvis that as we read
we are generating very low levels of
motor activity in our throat that is we
are speaking the words that we are
reading
at a level below the perception of sound
or our own perception of those words but
if one were to put an amplifier to
measure the firing of those muscles in
our vocal cords we'd find that as we're
reading information we are actually
speaking that information and as I
learned and you'll soon learn there's a
direct link between those species in the
world that have song and movement which
many of us would associate with dance
and our ability to learn and generate
complex language
so for people with speech disorders like
stutter or for people who are interested
in multiple language learning bilingual
trilingual Etc and frankly for anyone
who is interested in how we communicate
through words written or spoken I'm
certain today's episode is going to be
an especially interesting and important
one for you Dr Jarvis's work is so
pioneering that he has been awarded
truly countless Awards I'm not going to
take our time to list off all the
various important awards that he's
received but I should point out that in
addition to being a decorated professor
at the Rockefeller University he is also
an investigator with the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute the so-called hhmi and
for those of you that don't know hhmi
investigators are selected on an
extremely competitive basis
that they have to re-up that is they
have to recompete every five years they
actually receive a grade every five
years that dictates whether or not they
are no longer a Howard Hughes
investigator or whether or not they can
advance to another five years of funding
for their important research and indeed
Howard Hughes investigators are selected
not just for the rigor of their work but
for their pioneering spirit and their
ability to take on high risk High
benefit work which is exactly the kind
of work that Dr Jarvis has been
providing for decades now again I think
today's episode is one of the more
unique and special episodes that we've
had on the huberman Lab podcast I single
it out because it really spans from the
basic to the applied and Dr Jarvis's
story is an especially unique one in
terms of how he arrived at becoming a
neurobiologist so for those of you that
are interested in personal journey and
personal story Dr Jarvis's is truly a
special and important one I'm pleased to
announce that the huberman Lab podcast
is now partnered with momentous
supplements we partnered with momentous
for several important reasons first of
all they ship internationally because we
know that many of you are located
outside of the United States second of
all and perhaps most important the
quality of their supplements is second
to none both in terms of Purity and
precision of the amounts of the
ingredients
third we really emphasized supplements
that are single ingredient supplements
and that are supplied in dosages that
allow you to build a supplementation
protocol that's optimized for cost
that's optimized for Effectiveness and
that you can add things and remove
things from your protocol in a way
that's really systematic and scientific
if you'd like to see the supplements
that we partner with momentous on you
can go to livemomentis.com huberman
there you'll see those supplements and
just keep in mind that we are constantly
expanding the library of supplements
available through momentous on a regular
basis again that's livemomentis.com
huberman before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost and
consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better meet your immediate and long-term
health goals I've long been a believer
in getting regular blood work done for
the simple reason that many of the
factors that impact your immediate and
long-term Health can only be analyzed
from a quality blood test and nowadays
with the Advent of modern DNA test you
can also get insight into for example
what your biological age is and compare
that to your chronological age the
problem with a lot of DNA tests and
blood tests however is you get
information back about metabolic factors
lipids and hormones and so forth but you
don't know what to do with or about that
information inside tracker solves that
problem with a simple platform that
allows you to click on any specific
Factor learn more about it and what it
does in your brain and body and also the
various nutritional supplementation and
other types of interventions you can
take to bring the levels of that factor
into the ranges that are optimal for you
and your health
if you'd like to try inside tracker you
can go to insidetracker.com huberman to
get 20 off any of inside trackers plans
that's inside tracker.com huberman to
get 20 off today's episode is also
brought To Us by Roka Roku makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that are of
the absolute highest quality they also
have some really unique features that
make them especially attractive from the
standpoint of Aesthetics and performance
the company was founded by two
All-American swimmers from Stanford and
everything about their eyeglasses and
sunglasses were designed with
performance in mind initially the
eyeglasses and sunglasses were designed
for sport that is for running and for
cycling Etc and indeed still their
eyeglasses and sunglasses are very
lightweight and they won't slip off your
face if you get sweaty but they also
have a terrific aesthetic you can wear
them to work you can wear them out to
eat I wear readers at night when I work
or if I drive and I wear sunglasses
sometimes during the middle of the day
if it's too bright and I need sunglasses
in order to see if you'd like to try
Roca eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go
to Roka that's roka.com and enter the
code huberman to save 20 off your first
order again that's roka.com and enter
the code huberman at checkout today's
episode is also brought To Us by element
element is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't meaning no sugar but plenty of the
correct ratios of sodium magnesium and
potassium and those three electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium are
critical for your neuron your nerve cell
function and for the function of all the
cells in your brain and body I've
mentioned this before on the podcast but
I'm a fan of salt not taking too much
salt but certainly not getting too
little salt element has 1000 milligrams
that is one gram of salt which might
sound like a lot of salt but for many
people especially people who are
following low carbohydrate diets or who
are exercising or sweating a lot or both
that level of salt can actually help you
in many circumstances getting the
appropriate level of salt and certainly
the appropriate levels of electrolytes
will improve your cognitive function and
will improve your physical performance
if you'd like to try element you can go
to drink element that's lmnt.com
huberman and you'll get a free sample
pack with your order that's
drinklmnt.com huberman and now for my
discussion with Dr Eric Jarvis Eric so
great to have you here thank you yeah
very interested in learning from you
about speech and language and even as I
asked the question I realized that a lot
of people including myself probably
don't fully appreciate the distinction
between speech and language right speech
I think of as the motor patterns the
production of sound that has meaning
hopefully and language of course comes
in various languages and varieties of
ways of communicating but in terms of
the study of speech and language and
thinking about how the brain organizes
speech language what are the
similarities what are the differences
how should we think about speech and
language yeah
um well I'm glad you you know invited me
here and I'm also glad to get that first
question which I've been said a
provocative one really the reason why
uh I've been struggling what is the
difference with speech and language for
many years and realize why am I
struggling it's because there are
behavioral terms let's call them
psychologically psychology developed
kind of terms that don't actually align
exactly with brain function all right
and the question is there a distinction
between speech and language and when I
look at the brain of work that other
people have done work we have done also
comparative with animal models like
those who can imitate sounds like
parrots and songbirds I started to see
there really isn't such a sharp
distinction so so to get at what I think
is going on let me tell you how some
people think of it now that there's a
separate language module in the brain
that has all the algorithms and
computations that influence the speech
pathway on how to produce sound and the
auditory pathway on how to perceive and
interpret it uh for speech or for you
know sound that we call speech and
it turns out
I don't think there is any good evidence
for a separate language module instead
there is a speech production pathway
that's controlling our larynx
controlling our jaw muscles that has
built within it all the complex
algorithms for spoken language and
there's the auditory pathway that has
built within it all the complex
algorithms for understanding speech not
separate from a language module and the
speech production pathway is specialized
to humans
and parrots and songbirds whereas this
auditory perception pathway is more
ubiquitous amongst the animal kingdom
and this is why dogs can understand sit
siente say come here ball boy get the
ball and so forth dogs can understand
several hundred human speech words great
apes you can teach them for several
thousand but they can't say a word
fascinating
because you've raised a number of animal
species early on here and because I have
a basically an obsession with animals
since the time I was very small I have
to ask which animals have language
which animals have modes of
communication that are sort of like
language yeah um you know I've heard
whale songs I don't know what they're
saying they sound very beautiful but
they could be insulting each other for
all I know
um and they very well maybe
Dolphins birds I mean
what do we understand about modes of
communication that are like language but
might not be what would classically be
called language right so
so modes of communication that people
would Define as language Morse very in a
very narrow definition they would say
production of sound so speech
um but what about the hands to gesturing
with the hands what about a bird who is
doing aerial displays in the air
communicating information through body
language right well
um I'm going to go back to the brain so
what I think is going on is for spoken
language we're using the speech pathway
in all the complex algorithms there next
to the brain regions that are
controlling spoken language are the
brain regions for gesturing with the
hens
and that hand parallel pathway has also
complex algorithms that we can utilize
and some species are more advanced in
these circuits whether it's sound or
gesturing with hands and some or less
advanced
now we humans and a few others are the
most advanced for the speech sounds or
this or the spoken language but a
non-human primate can produce gesturing
in a more advanced form than they could
produce sound
I'm not sure I got that across clearly
just to say that
humans are the most advanced at spoken
language
but not necessarily as big a difference
at gestural language compared to some
other species
very clear and very interesting and and
immediately prompts the question uh have
there been brain Imaging or other sorts
of uh studies evaluating neural activity
in the context of
you know cultures and languages at least
that I associate with a lot of hand
movement like Italian versus uh I don't
know maybe you could give us some
examples of cultures where language is
not associated with with as much overt
hand movement yes so as you and I are
talking here today and people who are
listening but can't see us we're
actually gesturing with our hands as we
talk uh without knowing it or doing it
unconsciously and if we were talking on
a telephone I would have one hand here
and I'd be gesturing with the other hand
without even you seeing me right and so
why is that some have argued and I would
agree with based upon what we've seen is
that there is an evolutionary
relationship between the brain Pathways
that control speech production and
gesturing uh and and the Brain regions I
mentioned are directly adjacent to each
other and why is that I think that the
brain Pathways that control speech
evolved out of the brain Pathways that
control body movement
all right and
um that's uh when you talk about Italian
French English and so forth
um each one of those languages come with
a learned set of gestures
that you can communicate with now how is
that related to other animals well cocoa
or gorilla who is raised with humans for
39 years or more uh learned how to do
gesture
communication learn how to sign language
so to speak right but Coco couldn't
produce those sounds Coco could
understand them as well
by by seeing somebody sign or hearing
somebody produce speech but Coco
couldn't produce it with her voice
and so what's going on there is that a
number of species not all of them a
number of species have motor pathways in
the brain where you can do learn
gesturing rudimentary language if you
wanted to say with your lens even if
it's not as advanced as humans but they
don't have this extra brain pathway for
the sound so they can't gesture with
their voice in the way that they gesture
with their hands I see
one thing that I've wondered about for a
very long time is whether or not
primitive emotions
and primitive sounds are the early
substrate of language and whether or not
there's a bridge that we can draw
between those in terms of just
basic respiration systems associated
with different extreme feelings here's
the way I'm imagining this might work
when I smell something delicious
I typically inhale more and I might say
or something like that whereas if I
smell something putrid I typically turn
away I wince and I will exhale you know
or so kind of like turn away trying to
not ingest those molecules or inhale
those molecules I could imagine that
these are the basic dark and light
contrasts of the of the language system
and as I say that I'm saying that from
the orientation of a vision scientist
who thinks of all visual images built up
in a bit very basic way of a
hierarchical model of the ability to see
dark and light so I could imagine this
kind of primitive to more sophisticated
pyramid of of sound to language
is this a crazy idea do we have any uh
do we have any evidence this is the way
it works uh no it's not a crazy idea and
in fact you hit upon one of the key
distinctions in the field of research
that I started out in which is vocal
learning research so for vocal
communication
uh you have most vertebrate species
vocalize but most of them are producing
innate sounds that they're born with
producing that is babies crying for
example or dogs barking
uh and only a few species have learned
vocal communication the ability to
imitate sounds and that is what makes
spoken language special when people
think of what's special about language
it's to learn vocalizations it's what
that is what's rare and so this
distinction between innateness and
learned
um is more of a bigger dichotomy when it
comes to vocalizations than for other
behaviors in the animal kingdom
and uh when you go in the brain you see
it there as well and so all the things
you talked about the breathing the
grunting and so forth a lot of that is
handled by the brain stem circuits you
know right around the level of your neck
and Below uh like a reflex other thing
so or or even some emotional aspects of
your behavior in the hypothalamus and so
forth but for a learned behavior
learning how to speak uh learning how to
play the piano teaching a dog to learn
how to do tricks is using the four brain
circuits and what has happened is that
there's a lot of forebrain circuits that
are controlling learning how to move
body parts in these species but not for
the vocalizations but in humans and in
parrots in some other species somehow we
acquired circuits where the forebrain
has taken over the brain stem
and now using that brain stem not only
to produce the innate behaviors or vocal
behaviors but the Learned ones as well
do we have any sense of when
modern or sophisticated language
evolved you know thinking back to the
species that we evolved from and even
within Homo sapiens
um has there been an evolution of
language has there been a Devolution of
language yeah yeah I I would say
um
and and to be able to answer that
question it does come with the caveat
that I think we humans overrate
ourselves when it compared to other
species and so it makes uh even
scientists uh go astray in in trying to
hypothesize when you especially you
don't find fossil evidence of language
that easily uh in out there in terms of
what happened in the past
um we pride amongst the primates which
we humans belong to we are the only ones
that have this Advanced vocal learning
ability uh
now when you it was assumed that it was
only homo sapiens
uh then you can go back in time now
based upon genomic data not only of us
living humans but of the fossils that
have been found for Homo sapiens of
Neanderthals of denisovan individuals
and discover that our ancestor our human
ancestors supposedly hybridized with
these other hominid species
and it was assumed that these other
hominid species don't learn how to
imitate sounds
I don't know of any species today that's
a vocal learner that can have children
with a non-vocal learning species I I
don't see it doesn't mean it didn't
exist
and when we look at the genetic data
from these ancestral hominids that you
know where we could look at genes that
are involved in learn vocal
communication they have the same
sequence as we humans do
for genes that function in speech
circuits so I think neanderthals had
spoken language I'm not going to say
it's as advanced as what it is in humans
I don't know but I think it's been there
for at least between 500 000 to a
million years
uh that our ancestors had this ability
and that we've been coming more and more
advanced with it culturally and possibly
genetically
um but I think it's evolved sometime in
the last five hundred thousand to a
million years incredible yeah
maybe we could talk a little bit more
about the overlap between brain circuits
that control language and speech in
humans and other animals uh
you know I was weaned in the in the
Neuroscience era where Birdsong and the
uh the ability of birds to learn their
Tudor song was it was and still is a
prominent field in um subfield of
Neuroscience and then of course
neuroimaging of uh humans speaking and
learning Etc and this notion of a
critical period a time in which language
is learned more easily than it is later
in life and the names of the different
brain areas were quite different
um it one opens the textbooks we hear
Wernicke's and brocas for the humans and
you look at the birds of it I remember
you know HPC robust art striatum area X
that's right yeah Etc but um for most of
our listeners that those names won't
mean a whole lot but um but in terms of
homologies
between areas in terms of function what
do we know and how similar or different
are the brains a brain areas controlling
speech and language and say a songbird
and a young human child yeah so so going
back to the 1950s or and even a little
earlier and Peter Mahler and others who
got involved in neuroethology the study
of neurobiology of behavior in a natural
way right
you know they start to find that
behaviorally there are these species of
birds like sombers and parents and now
we also know hummingbirds just three of
them out of the 40-something bird groups
out there on the planet orders that they
can imitate sounds like we do and so
that was a similarity in other words
they had this kind of behavior that's
more similar to us than chimpanzees have
with us or than chickens have with them
right they're closer relatives and then
they discovered even more similarities
these critical periods that if you
remove a child on you know this
unfortunately happens where a child is
feral and is not raised with human and
goes through their puberty phase of
growth it becomes hard for them to learn
a language as an adult so there's this
critical period where you learn best and
even later on when you're in regular
Society it's hard to learn while the
scent Birds undergo the same thing and
then it was discovered that if they
become deaf we humans become deaf our
speed starts to deteriorate without any
kind of therapy uh if a non-human
primate or
um you know or let's say a chicken
becomes deaf their vocalizations don't
deteriorate very little at least uh well
this happens in the vocal learning Birds
so there were all these behavioral
parallels that came along with a package
and then people looked into the brain
Fernando nadevan my former PhD advisor
and began to discover the area X you
talked about the robust nucleus of the
archopalian and
um
and these brain Pathways were not found
in the species who couldn't imitate so
there was a parallel here and then uh
jumping many years later you know I
started to dig down into these brain
circuits to discover that these brain
circuits had parallel functions with the
brain circuits for humans even though
they're by a different name like brocas
and Lorenzo motor cortex and most
recently we discovered not only the
actual circuitry and the connectivity
are similar but the underlying genes
that are expressed in these brain
regions in a specialized way different
from the rest of the brain are also
similar between humans and Somers and
parrots so all the way down to the genes
and now we're finding the specific
mutations
are also similar not always identical
but similar which indicates remarkable
convergence for a so-called complex
behavior in species separated by 300
million years from a common ancestor and
not only that we are discovering that
mutations in these genes that cause
speech deficits in humans like in Fox P2
if you put those same mutations or
similar type of deficits in these vocal
learning Birds you get similar deficits
so convergence of the behavior is
associated with similar genetic
disorders of the behavior incredible I
have to ask do hummingbirds sing or do
they hum
hummingbirds hum with their wings and
sing with their searings in a
coordinated way in a coordinated way
there's some species of hummingbirds
that actually will
um Doug ashler showed this that will
flap uh their wings and create a
slapping sound with their wings that's
in unison with their song and oh and you
would not know it but it sounds like a
particular syllable in their songs uh
even though it's their wings and their
voice at the same time hummingbirds are
clapping to their song clapping with
their they're snapping their wings
together uh in unison with a song to to
make it like if I'm going to
you know I banged on the table except
they make it almost sound like their
voice with their wings
incredible yes I I'm and they got some
of the smartest kids would say mind
blown yeah right yes incredible yes
incredible I love hummingbirds and I
always feel like it's such a a special
thing to get in a moment to see one
because they move around so fast and
they flit away so fast in these
ballistic trajectories that when you get
to see one stationary for a moment or
even just hovering there it's you feel
like you're extracting so much from
their little low microcosm of life but
now I realize they're they're playing
music right exactly and what's amazing
about hummingbirds and I we're gonna say
vocal learning species in general is
that for whatever reason they seem to
evolve multiple complex traits you know
this idea that the evolving language
spoken language in particular comes
along with a set of specializations
incredible
when I was coming up in Neuroscience I
learned that I think it was the work of
Peter marlar that
um young birds learn songbirds learn
their Tudor song
and learn it quite quite well but that
they could learn the song of another
tutor in other words they could learn a
different and for the listeners I'm
doing air quotes here a different
language a different bird song different
than their own species yeah but never as
well as they could learn their own
natural
genetically linked song Yes genetically
meaning that they would be like me being
raised in a different culture and um
that I would learn that the other
language but not as well as I would have
learned English this this is the idea
yes is that true that is true yes and
that's and that's what I learned growing
up as well and and talk to Peter Mahler
himself about before he passed
um yeah this he used to call it the
innate predisposition to learn all right
so
um which would be kind of the equivalent
in the linguistic community of universal
grammar there is something genetically
influencing our vocal communication on
top of what we learn culturally and so
there's this balance between the genetic
control of speech or a song in these
birds and the Learned cultural control
and so so yes if you were to take
um you know
um I mean in this case we actually tried
this at Rockefeller later on take a
Zebra Finch and raise it with a canary
it would sing a song that was sort of
like a hybrid in between we call it a
knich right
uh and vice versa for the canary because
there's something different about their
vocal musculature or the or the
circuitry in the brain and with a zebra
finch even with a closely related
species if you would take a Zebra Finch
a young animal and in one cage next to
it Place its own species adult male
right and in the other cage Place
bengalese Finch next to it it would
preferably learn the song from its own
species his neighbor but if you remove
its neighbor it would learn that
bengalese Finch very well fantastic so
there's it has something to do with also
the social bonding with your own species
incredible
that raises a question that I've based
on something I also heard but I don't
have any uh scientific peer-reviewed
publication to point to which is this
this idea of pigeon not the bird but
this idea of when multiple cultures and
languages converge in a given geographic
area that the children of all the
different Native languages will come up
with their own language I think this was
in Island culture maybe in Hawaii called
pigeon which is sort of a hybrid of the
various languages that their parents
speak at home and that they themselves
speak and that somehow pigeon again not
the bird but a language called pigeon
for reasons I don't know
Harbors certain basic elements of all
language is that true is that not true I
I would I haven't studied enough myself
in terms of pigeon specifically but in
terms of cultural evolution of language
and hybridization between different
cultures and so forth uh even amongst
birds with different dialects and you
bring them together uh you know what is
going on here is
cultural Evolution remarkably tracks
genetic Evolution so if you bring people
from two separate populations together
that have been in their separate
populations evolutionarily at least for
hundreds of generations so someone's
speaking Chinese someone's speaking
English and that child then's learning
from both of them yes that child is
going to be able to pick up and merge uh
uh funims and words together in a way
that an adult wouldn't because why
they're experiencing both languages at
the same time during their critical
period years in a way that adults would
not be able to experience and so you get
a hybrid and the lowest common
denominator is going to be what they
share and so the phonemes that they've
retained in each of their uh languages
is what's going to be I imagine used the
most
interesting
so we've got
brain circuits in songbirds and in
humans that in many ways are similar
perhaps not in their exact wiring but in
their basic Contour of wiring and genes
that are expressed in both sets of
neural circuits in very distinct species
that are responsible for these these
phenomena we're calling speech and
language
what sorts of things are those genes
controlling what's I could imagine they
were controlling the wiring of
connections between brain areas you know
essentially a map of you know of a
circuit basically like an engineer which
is on a circuit for speech and language
major design the search for speech and
language but presumably other things too
like the ability to
um connect
motor patterns within the throat of
muscles within the throat when the
control of the tongue I mean what are
these genes doing you're pretty good
yeah you've made some very good guesses
there that makes sense uh
so so yes uh one of the things that
differ in the speech Pathways of us and
these so on Pathways of birds is some of
the connections are fundamentally
different than the surrounding circuits
like a um a direct cortical connection
uh from the areas that control
vocalizations in the cortex the motor
neurons that control the larynx in
humans or the serings and birds and so
we actually made a prediction uh that
since some of these connections differ
we're going to find genes that that
control neurodeconnectivity uh and that
specialize in that function that differ
and that's exactly what we found uh the
genes that control what we call axon
guidance and formation and connections
and what was interesting it was sort of
in the opposite direction than we
expected that is
some of these genes actually a number of
them that control neurodeconnectivity
were turned off
in the speech circuit all right and it
didn't make sense to us at first and so
we started to realize the function of
these genes are to repel connections
from forming so repulsive molecules and
so when you turn them off they allow
certain connections to form that
normally would have not formed so it's
so by turning it off you've got to gain
a function for speech right
um other genes that surprised us were
genes involved in calcium buffering
neural protection
like a par valueman or heat shock
protein so when your brain gets hot
these proteins turn on and we couldn't
figure out for a long time why is that
the case
and then the idea popped to me one day
and said ah when I heard the larynx is
the fastest firing muscles in the body
all right in order to vibrate sound and
and modulate sound in the way we do you
have to control you have to move those
muscles you know three to four to five
times faster than just regular walking
or running
and so um when you stick electrodes in
in the brain areas that control learn
vocalizations in these birds and I think
in humans as well those neurons are
firing at a higher rate to control these
muscles and so what is that going to do
you're going to have lots of toxicity in
those neurons unless you upregulate
molecules that take out uh the extra
load that is needed to control the
larynx and then finally a third set of
genes that are you specialize in these
speech circuit are involved in
neuroplasticity
uh neuroplasticity meaning allowing the
brain circuits to be more flexible uh so
you can learn better and why is that I
think learning how to produce speech is
a more complex learning ability than say
learning how to walk or or learning how
to do tricks and jumps and so forth that
dogs do yeah it's interesting as you say
that because I I realize that many
aspects of speech are sort of reflexive
I'm not thinking about each word I'm
going to say they just sort of roll out
of my mouth hopefully with some
forethought we both know people that uh
seem to speak uh think less fewer
synapses between their brain and their
mouth than others right a lot of
examples out there and some people are
very deliberate in their speech but
nonetheless that much of speech is uh
has to be precise and some of it less
precise in terms of plasticity of speech
and the ability to learn multiple
languages but even just one language
what's going on in the critical period
the so-called critical period yeah why
is it that
um so my niece speaks Spanish
she's Guatemala and speak Spanish and
English incredibly well she's 14 years
old I've struggled with Spanish my whole
life my father is bilingual my mother is
not I've tried to learn Spanish as as an
adult it's
really challenging I'm told that had I
learned it when I was eight I would be
better off that's right um or it would
be installed Within Me so the first
question is is it easier to learn
multiple languages without an accent
early in life and if so why and then the
second question is if one can already
speak more than one language as a
consequence of childhood learning is it
easier to acquire new languages later on
so so the answer to both of those
questions is yes in that um but but I
but to explain this
I need to let you know actually the
entire brain
uh is undergoing a critical period
development not just the speech Pathways
and uh so it's easier to learn how to
play a piano it's easier to learn how to
ride a bike for the first time and so
forth as a young child than it is uh
later in life what I mean easier in
terms of when you start from you start
from first principles of learning
something so the very first time if
you're going to learn Chinese as a child
versus the very first time you learn
Chinese as an adult or learning play
piano as a child versus an adult uh but
the speech Pathways or let's say speech
Behavior I think has a stronger critical
period uh change to it than other
circuits uh and why what's going on
there in general
uh if you
uh why do you need a critical period to
make you more stable uh to make you more
stubborn so to speak uh the reason I
believe is that the brain is not for
brain Can Only Hold so much information
and uh if you are undergoing rapid
learning to learn to acquire new
knowledge you also have to
you know dumb stuff put put memory or
information in the trash like in a
computer you only have so many gigabases
of memory and so therefore um plus also
for survival you don't want to keep
forgetting things and so so the brain is
designed I believe
to undergo this critical period and
solidify the circuits with what you
learned as a child and you use that for
the rest of your life and we humans stay
even more plastic in our brain functions
controlled by a gene called srgap2 we
have an extra copy of it that leaves our
speech circuit and other brain regions
in a more immature State throughout life
compared to other animals so we're more
immature we're still juvenile like
compared to other animals I knew it but
we but we still go through the critical
periods like they all do and now the
question you asked about if you learn
more
languages as a child can you is it
easier to learn as an adult and that's a
common uh finding out there in the
literature there are some that argue
against it but for those that support it
the idea there is
um you you are born with a set of innate
sounds you can produce the phonons
and you narrow that down because not all
languages use all of them and so you
narrow down the ones you use to string
the phonemes together and the words that
you learn and you maintain those
phonemes as an adult and here comes
along another language that's using
those phones or in in different
combinations you're not used to and
therefore you it's like starting from
first principles but if you already have
them in multiple languages that you're
using then it makes it easier to use
them in another third or fourth language
I I see incredible so so it's not like
your brain has under has maintained
greater plasticity is your your brain
has maintained greater ability to
produce different sounds that then
allows you to learn another language
faster got it
are the hand gestures associated with
sounds or with meanings of words
I think the hand gestures associated
with both the sounds and the meaning of
when I say sound like if you are really
angry right uh and you are making a loud
screaming noise right you may make hand
gestures that are look like you're going
to beat the Wall right because you're
making loud sounds and Loud gestures all
right
um but if you want to explain something
like come over here what I just do now
to you for those who can't see me I
swung my hand towards you and swung it
here to me that has a meaning to it to
come here so just like with the voice
this the hand gestures are producing
both uh uh you know both qualities of
sounds and for people that speak
multiple languages especially those that
learn in those multiple languages early
in development do they switch their
patterns of motor movements according to
let's say going from Italian to Arabic
or from Arabic to French in a way that
matches the the Precision of language
that they're speaking you know what you
just asked me a question I don't know
the answer to I would imagine that would
make sense because of of of switching uh
in terms of sometimes people might call
this code switching even different
dialects of the same language could you
do that with your gestures I imagine so
but I really don't know if that's true
or not well I certainly don't know from
my own experience because I only speak
one language
before we continue with today's
discussion I'd like to just briefly
acknowledge our sponsor athletic greens
now called ag1
athletic greens AKA ag-1 is an
all-in-one vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that also has adaptogens and
digestive enzymes I've been taking
athletic greens since way back in 2012
so I'm delighted that they're sponsoring
the podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
drink athletic greens twice a day is
that it supplies total foundational
coverage of my vitamin mineral needs and
IT Supplies important nutrients that I
need to support my gut microbiome the
gut microbiome as many of you know
supports the immune system it also
supports the so-called gut brain axis
which is vital for mood for energy
levels regulating focus and many other
features of our mental health and
physical health that impact our daily
performance and high performance in any
Endeavors we might be involved in if
you'd like to try athletic greens you
can go to athleticgreens.com huberman
and claim a special offer they're giving
away five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 with every order
and of course vitamin D3 K2 are vital
for all sorts of things like Hormone
Health and metabolic health and K2 for
cardiovascular health and calcium
regulation again you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman to claim
that special offer to go a little bit
into the abstract but not too far what
about modes of speech and language that
seem to have a depth of emotionality and
meaning but for which it departs from
structured language here's what I mean
uh poetry uh I think of musicians like
there's some Bob Dylan songs that to me
I understand the individual words
I like to think there's an emotion
associated with it at least I experience
some sort of emotion and I have a guess
about what he was experiencing but if I
were to just read it linearly without
the music and without him singing it or
somebody singing it like him it wouldn't
hold any meaning so in other words
words that seem to have meaning but not
associated with language but somehow tap
into an emotionality
yep absolutely so so we call this
difference
um semantic communication communication
with meaning and effective communication
communication that has more of an
emotional feeling content to it you know
but not with you know the semantics and
the two can be mixed up like with
singing words that have meaning but also
have this effective emotional you just
love the sound of the singer that you're
hearing and uh initially
um uh you know psychologist scientists
in general thought that these were going
to be controlled by different brain
circuits uh and and it is the case there
are emotional brain centers and a
hypothalamus in the singulate cortex and
so forth that do give tone to the sounds
but
um I believe you know based upon Imaging
work and work we see in Birds when when
birds are communicating semantic
information and there's sounds which is
not too often but it happens versus uh
effective communication sing because I'm
trying to attract the mate my courtship
song or defend my territory it's the
same brain circuits it's the same speech
like or song circuits are being used in
different ways
uh a friend of mine who's also a
therapist said to me you know it's
possible to say I love you with intense
hatred and to say I hate you with
intense love right and uh reminding me
that it's possible to hear both of those
statements uh in either way so uh I
guess it's not just limited to song or
poetry it also there's something about
the intention
and the emotional context in which
something's spoken that it can heavily
shape the way that uh we interpret what
we hear that's right and and and I
consider all of that actually meaning
even though I defined it as
as people commonly do semantic and
effective communication
effective communication to say I hate
you but meant love right is
um does have emotional meaning to it you
know and so you know one's more like an
object kind of meaning or an abstract
kind of meaning there's several other
points here I think it's important for
for the those listening out there to
hear is that when I say also this
effective and
um semantic communication
um being used by similar brain circuits
it also matters the side of the brain uh
in birds and in humans
um there's there's Left Right dominance
for learned communication learn sound
communication uh so the left in US
humans is more dominant for speech
but the right has a more balance for
singing or processing musical sounds as
opposed to processing speech both get
used for both reasons and so when people
say your right brain is your artistic
brain and your left brain is your
thinking brain this is what they're
referring to uh and uh so that's another
distinction the second thing that's
useful to know is that all vocal
learning species use their learn sounds
for this emotional effective kind of
communication
but only a few of them like humans and
some parrots and dolphins use it for the
semantic kind of communication we
calling speech and and that has led a
number of people to hypothesize that the
evolution of spoken language of speech
Evolved first for singing for this more
like emotional kind of made attraction
like the Jennifer Lopez the Ricky Martin
kind of songs and so forth uh and then
later on it became used for abstract
communication like we're doing now how
interesting well that's a perfect segue
for me to be able to ask you about your
background
um and motor control not only of the
hands but of the body so you have a
number of important distinctions to your
name but one of them is that you were a
member of the Alvin Ailey Dance uh
school school that's right that's right
um so you're you're an accomplished or
and quite able dancer right
um tell us a little bit about your
background in the the World of Dance and
as how it informs your interest in their
Neuroscience excuse me and perhaps even
how it relates specifically to your work
on speech and language yes well it's
interesting and then this kind of
History even goes before my time so in
my family my mother and father's side
they both went to the high school of
music and art here in New York City uh
and particularly my mother's family
going back multiple Generations they
were singers and I even did my family
genealogy and found out not only you
know we have some relationships to some
well-known singers distant relationships
like felonious monk but going back to
the plantations in North Carolina and so
forth my ancestors were singers in the
church for the you know the towns and so
forth and this somehow got passed on
multiple generations to my family and I
thought I was going to grow up and be a
famous singer right and my me and my
brothers and sister formed the band when
we were kids and and so forth and but it
turned out that I didn't inherit these
singing talents of some my other family
members even though you know
okay you know but not like my brother or
not like my mother or my aunts and my
cousin putafe who's now a talented
Native American singer and so um so uh
what that then influenced me to do other
things and I started uh you know
competing in dance contests uh you know
actually this is around the time of the
Saturday Night Fever and I was as a
teenager and I started when winning
dance contests and I thought oh I can
dance and I auditioned for the High
School of Performing Arts and I got in
here in New York City and got into a
ballet dance and got in right and and
thought if I learned ballet I can learn
everything else it was that idea if you
learned something classical it can teach
you for everything else uh and I was
yeah at Alvin Ali dance school Joffrey
Ballet dance school and at the end of my
senior uh uh concert uh I was had this
opportunity to audition for the Alvin
Ali dance company and I had an
opportunity to go to college and I also
fell in love with another passion that
my father had which was science
and so I liked science in high school
and I found an overlap also between the
Arts and Sciences you know both require
creativity hard work discipline you know
new discovery both weren't boring to me
and the one decision I made at that at
that senior dance concert was you know
when talking to the Alvin Ailey
recruiter and thinking about it I have
to make a decision
and I thought
something my mother taught me because
she was growing up in the 1960s cultural
revolution do something that has a
positive impact on society and I thought
I can do that better as a dancer than a
scientist
so now jump I get into college
undergraduate school I major in
molecular biology and Mathematics I
decide I want to be a biologist got into
graduate school wanted to study the the
brain at you know the Rockefeller
University so I went from Hunter College
to Rockefeller University and so now I
got to the brain and I said and why did
I choose the brain is because it
controls dancing
but I didn't there was anybody studying
dancing and I wanted to study the brain
something that it does that's really
interesting and complex and I thought ah
language is what it does you couldn't
study that in mice you couldn't study in
non-human primates but these birds do
this wonderful thing that Fernando
notabon was studying at Rockefeller and
so that's what got me into the birds uh
and um
uh and then jumping now 15 years later
you know yeah that's right even after
I'm into now having my own lab studying
vocal learning in these birds as a model
for language and humans it turns out
that uh uh you know Ani Patel and uh you
know others uh have discovered um that
uh only vocal learning species can learn
how to dance
is that right that's right yes
so I've seen these um just scrolling
through the the files here in my in my
mind I think about every once in a while
someone was I loved uh parrots yeah um
every once in a while someone will send
me one of these little Instagram or
Twitter videos of a parrot doing what
looks to me like dance typically it's a
cockatoo that's right right that's right
even foot stomping to the sound and
famous one called snowball out there but
there are no there are many snowballs
out there yeah they're all all the
dancing birds are named snowball um
that's interesting tactic
um so only animals with Language Dance
yeah vocal learning in particular the
ability to imitate sounds
yes incredible yes and this now is
bringing my life full circle
all right and I and and so when that was
discovered in 2009 uh at that same time
in my lab at Duke we had discovered that
vocal learning brain Pathways insom
birds as well as in humans and in
parrots right like snowball uh are
embedded within circuits that control
learning how to move
and that led us to ethereal called the
brain pathway or motor theory of vocal
learning origin where the brain Pathways
for vocal learning and speech evolved by
a whole duplication of the surrounding
motor circuits involving learning how to
move
now how does that explain dance right
well when when Snowball the cockatoos
are dancing they're using the brain
regions around their speech-like
circuits to to do this dancing behavior
and so what's going on there what we
what we hypothesize and now like to test
is that when this when when speech
evolved in humans and the equivalent
behavior in parrots and songbirds it
required a very tight integration in the
brain regions that can hear a sound
with the brain regions that control your
muscles from moving your larynx and
tongue and so forth for producing sound
in that tight auditory motor integration
we argued then contaminated the
surrounding brain regions
and that contamination of the
surrounding brain reagents now allows us
humans in particular in parrots to
coordinate our muscle movements of the
rest of the body with sound in the same
way we do for speech sounds
well so we're speaking with our bodies
when we dance incredible and and I have
to say that as poor as I am at speaking
multiple languages I'm even worse at
dancing so
um but I guarantee you're better than a
uh monkey but not Snowball the cockatoo
maybe not one on YouTube we have a video
where there's some scientists dancing
with snowball and you'll see snowballs
doing better than some of the scientists
okay well as long as I'm not the worst
of all scientists are dancing
um
there's always some real plasticity may
it save me someday
you said something incredible that I've
I I completely believe even though I
have
um minimum to let's just say minimum
dancing ability okay I can get by at a
part of your wedding without complete
embarrassment but I don't have any
structured training
um so
the body clearly can communicate with
movement as a trained dancer and knowing
other trained dancers
I always think of
dance and bodily movement and
communication through bodily movement as
a form of a wordlessness like a state of
wordlessness in fact the few times when
I think that maybe I'm actually dancing
modestly well for the context that I'm
in where I see other people dancing they
seem to just be very much in the
movement it's almost like a state of
non-language uh non-spoken language
um and and yet what you're telling me is
that there's a a direct bridge at some
level between the movement of the body
and and language so is there a language
of the body that is distinct from the
language of speech and
if so or if not how do those map onto
one another what's that Venn diagram
look like yeah yeah so so so let me
Define first stance in this context of
vocal learning species this is the kind
of dancing that we are specialized in
doing and other in the vocal learning
species we specialize in doing is
synchronizing body movements of muscles
to the rhythmic beats of music and for
some reason we like doing it we like
synchronizing to sounds uh and doing it
together as a group of people and that
kind of communication amongst ourselves
is more like the effective kind of
communication I mentioned earlier unlike
the semantic kind so we humans are using
our voices more for the semantic
abstract communication but we're using
learn dance for the effective emotional
bonding kind of communication it doesn't
mean we can't communicate semantic
information in dance and we do it
but it's not as popular you know like a
ballet that you know in the Nutcracker
it is popular you know where they are
communicating you know um the Arabian
guy comes out which I was the Arabian
guy in the ballet nutcracket as I
remember yeah for the Westchester Ballet
Company when I was a teenager uh you
know we're trying to communicate meaning
in our ballet dance and it can go on
with a whole story and so forth and but
people don't interpret that as clearly
as speech you know they're seeing the
ballet with semantic communication with
a lot of emotional content
whereas you go out to a club you know
yeah you're you're not coming
communicating he okay how are you
feeling today tell me about your day and
so forth you're trying to synchronize
with other people in an effective way
and I think that's because
the the dance brain circuit inherited
the more ancient part of the speech
circuit which was for singing I always
had the feeling that with certain forms
of Music
um a particular Opera but any kind of
music where there are some long notes
um sung that at some level there was a a
literal resonance created between the
singer and the listener that
um or I think of like the deep voice of
a Johnny Cash or where at some level you
can almost feel the voice in your own
body and in theory that could be the the
vibration of the the or the firing of
the phrenic nerve controlling the
diaphragm for all I know is there any
evidence that there's a coordination
between performer and audience at the at
the level of mind and body
um
I'm going to say possibly yes and the
reason why is because I just came back
from a conference on the neurobiology of
dance uh um that clearly I'm going to
the wrong meeting the colleague you know
vision science might be so boring yes
well one of my colleagues Tecumseh Fitch
and Jonathan Fritz they are organized a
particular section on on this conference
in Virginia and this is the first time I
was in the room with so many
neuroscientists studying the
neurobiology of dance it's a new field
now in the last five years and
um there was one a lab where they were
putting EEG electrodes on the dancers
on two different dancers partnering with
each other as well as uh the audience
you know uh seeing the dance and and
some you know argued okay if you're
listening to the music as well how are
you responding because you're you're
asking a question about music and I'm
giving you an answer about dance
and what they found is that you know uh
the dancers when they resonated with
each other during a dance or the
audience listening to the dancers and
the music there's some resonance going
on there that they've scored as higher
resonance their brain activity with
these Wireless EEG signals are showing
something different and so that's why I
say possibly yet it needs to it needs
more rigorous study uh and you know this
is some stuff they publish but it's not
prime time yet but they're trying to
figure this out love it so at least um
if I can't dance well maybe I can hear
and feel what it is to dance in a
certain way that that's right and and
this will be some people will think that
they even songs that they hear uh and
they can almost sing to themselves in
their own head and they know what they
want it to sound like and you know when
it really sounds good what it sounds
like but they can't get their voice to
do it I'm raising for those listening
I'm raising my hand uh no no musical
ability uh others in my household have
tremendous musical ability with
instruments and with voice but uh not me
yeah well and and so this is one of my
one of my
um selfish goals of trying to find the
genetics of whys can some people sing
really well and some not is there some
genetic predisposition to that and then
can I modify my own muscles or brain
circuits to sing better you're still
after the the thing I guess this is what
happens when siblings are very area in
proficiency is that that competitiveness
amongst uh brothers and sisters never
goes away I've been trying to be as good
as my brother Mark and Victor you know
for uh the whole my entire life like
watch out Mark and Victor he's coming
for you with Neuroscience right to back
him earlier you said that you discovered
that you could dance that that caught my
ear
um it sounds like you didn't actually
have to I'm not suggesting you didn't
work hard at it but that at the moment
where you discovered it
um it just sort of was a a skill that
you had that up until that point you
didn't Target a life in in the world of
dance but the fact that you quote
unquote discovered that you could dance
really well and then went to this
incredible School of Dance and and did
well
um tells me that perhaps there is a an
ability that was built up in childhood
and or that perhaps we do all have
different genetic leanings for for
different motor functions yeah well for
me there could be both explanations
could be possible for the first
um yeah I grew up in a family listening
to Motown songs you know dancing you
know at uh parties and so forth family
parties and you know an African-American
family basically and uh so so I agree
grew up dancing from a young child but
this this discovery you know maybe
dancing even more so uh uh in terms of
of a talent
it could the genetic component if it
really exists I don't know you know with
my 23andMe uh results you know it says I
have uh the genetic substitutions that
are associated with uh you know high
intensity athletes and fast twist
muscles and who knows maybe that could
have something to do with me being able
to synchronize uh my body to rhythmic
sounds
maybe maybe better than some others
um it turns out that my genetics also
show that I have a genetic substitute
that doesn't that makes it hard for me
to sing on pitch and so that does
correlate with my you know even though I
can sing on this pitch especially if I
hear a piano uh or you know kind of
playing it but uh you know maybe that's
why my siblings you know who didn't have
that genetic predisposition in his
23andMe results you know it could go
along with the genetic uh component as
well I'm imagining family gatherings
with 23andMe data and an intense
argument events about it yeah innate and
learned ability yes fun
um love to be an attendant I'm not
inviting myself to your Thanksgiving
dinner by the way but I suppose I am
you're welcome to thank you uh I'll
bring my 23andMe data I'd love to chat a
moment about facial expression because
that's a form of motor pattern that you
know I think for most people out there
um just think about smiling and frowning
but they're of course you know thousands
if not millions of micro expressions and
things of that sort many of which are
subconscious
um and we're we are all familiar with
the fact that when what somebody says
doesn't match some specific feature of
their facial expression that it can
um call you know that mismatch can cue
our attention especially among people
that know each other very well yeah like
you somebody will say well you said that
but you your right eye twitch to the you
know a little bit in a way that tells me
that you didn't really mean that this
these kinds of things or when in the
opposite example when the emotionality
and the content of our speech is matched
to a facial expression there's something
that's just so
um wonderful about that because it seems
like everything's aligned yeah so how
does the motor circuitry that controls
facial expression map on to the the
brain circuits that control language
speech and even bodily and hand movement
yes uh you you ask a great question
because we both know some colleagues
like minwik five old at Rockefeller
University who study facial expression
in the neurobiology behind it and now we
both share some students that we're
co-mentoring and talk about this same
question that you brought up and what
I'm learning a lot is that non-human
primates have a lot of diversity in
their facial expression like we humans
do and what we know about the
neurobiology of brain regions
controlling those muscles of the face is
that these non-human primates and some
other species that don't learn how to
imitate vocalizations they have
strong connections from the cortical
regions to the motor neurons that
control facial expressions
but absent connections or weak
connections to the motor neurons that
control the voice
so I think our diverse facial expression
even though it's more diverse in these
non-human primates there was already a
pre-existing diversity of communication
whether it's intentional or unconscious
through facial expression in our
ancestors
and on top of that we humans now add The
Voice
along with those facial expressions I
see the and in terms of language
learning when we're kids I mean children
fortunately are not told to fake their
expressions or to smile when they say
I'm happy
um so at some point everybody learns for
better for worse how to uh untangle
these different components of hand
movement body posture speech and facial
expression yes but in it in their best
form I would say
um assuming that the best form is always
I guess there are instances where you
know for safety reasons one might need
to feign some of these uh some of these
aspects of language but in most cases
when those are aligned
um it seems like that could reflect that
all the different circuitries are
operating in parallel but that the the
ability to misalign these is also a
powerful aspect to our maturation I I
even think of theater for instance where
deliberate disentangling of of these
areas is important but also we know when
an actor when it feels real yeah um and
when it looks like when bad acting is
oftentimes when the facial expression or
body posture just doesn't quite match
what we're hearing yeah so are these
skills that that people that learn and
acquire according to adaptability and
profession or do you think that all
children and all adults eventually learn
how to couple and uncouple these
circuits a little bit yeah I I think
it's it's this similar argument I
mentioned earlier about the innate and
learn for the vocalizations and by the
way when I say we humans have facial
expressions associated with our
vocalizations in a different way than
primates non-human primates it's the
Learned vocalizations I'm talking about
so there is a
common view out there that facial
expressions and non-human species like
non-human primates or you can have them
in Birds too or um
innate all right and so they're they're
they're reflexive and controlled I don't
believe that I think there's some
learned component to it and I think we
have more learning component to it as
well but
we also have an innate component and so
if you try to put your hands behind your
back and and hold your fist or even just
not and try to speak and try to
communicate it's actually harder to do
you have to force yourself or put it by
by your side this comes naturally facial
expressions comes naturally because
there's an innate component and yes you
have to learn how to dissociate the two
communicate something angry with your
hands or with your face but
um you know uh politely with your voice
it's very hard to distinct to separate
at this too because there is that innate
component that brings them together
um so it's like an email too you're
emailing and someone says something by
email someone can interpret that angrily
or or gently uh and it becomes ambiguous
the facial expressions get rid of that
ambiguity I'm so glad you brought that
out because my next question was and is
about written language uh the first
question I'll ask is when you write
either type or write things out by hand
do you hear the content of what you want
to write in your head you just you
personally
yes I do yeah I I I and I know that I do
because I was trying to figure out a
debate about this issue and trying to
resolve the debate with my own
self-experimentation on me I asked that
because a quite well-known colleague of
ours Carl diceroth at Stanford who's
been on this podcast and you know of
optogenetics Fame and Psychiatry Fame
Etc and then I I know him yeah um he
sends his regards yeah it told me that
um his practice for writing and for
thinking involves a quite painful
process of forcing himself to sit
completely still
and think in complete sentences to force
thinking in complete sentences and when
he told me that I decided to try this
exercise and it's quite difficult first
of all it's difficult for the reason
that you mentioned which is that with
many thoughts I want to look around and
I start to gesticulate with my hands
right so there it is again the
connection between language and hand
movement even if one isn't speaking the
and the other part is that I that's
challenging is I realize that while we
write in complete sentences most of the
time we'll talk about how that's
changing now and texting Etc that
we don't often think in complete
sentences and specifically in simple
declarative sentences that a lot of our
thoughts would be if we're if they were
written out onto a page would look
pretty much like passive language that a
good copy editor or a good editor would
say oh like we need to cross this out
make this simple and declarative so what
I'm getting at here is what is the
process of going from a thought to
language to written word and
I also wanted to touch on handwritten
versus typed but thought to language to
written word what's going on there what
do we know about the neural circuitry
and I was going to ask why is it so hard
but now I want to ask why is this even
possible it seems like a very
challenging neural computational problem
yeah yeah and and from coming from the
linguistic world and even just the
regular neurobiology world going back to
something I said before is about a
separate language module in the brain
you know there was this thought or
hypothesis that this language module has
all these complex algorithms to them and
they're signaling to the speech circuit
how to produce the sounds the hand
circuit how to write them or gesture uh
the visual pathway on how to interpret
them from reading and the auditory
pathway for listening
I don't think that's the case all right
uh and you know that this thinking where
where there's this internal speech going
on what I think is going on is to
explain what you're asking is about
that I'm going to take it from the
perspective reading something you read
something on a paper the signal from the
paper goes through your eyes it goes to
the back of your brain to your visual
cortical regions eventually uh and then
you now got to interpret that signal in
your visual pathway of what you're
reading how are you going to do that in
terms of speech that visual signal then
goes to your speech pathway in the motor
cortex in front here in Broca's area and
you silently speak what you read in your
brain without moving your muscles
sometimes actually if you put electrodes
EEG EMG electrodes on your laryngeal
muscles even on birds you can do this
you'll see activity there while reading
or or trying to speak silently even
though no sounds coming out
and so your
speech pathway is now speaking what
you're reading
now to finish it off that signal is sent
to your auditory pathway so you can hear
what you're speaking in your own head
that's incredible and this is why it's
complicated because you're using like
three different Pathways the visual the
speaking motor one and the auditory to
read oh and then you gotta write right
okay here comes the fourth one now the
hand area is next to your speech pathway
has got to take that auditory signal or
even the adjacent motor signals for
speaking and translate it into a visual
signal on paper
so so you're using at least four brain
circuits
which includes the speech production in
the speech perception Pathways to write
incredible and
finally explains to me why when I so I
was weaned teaching undergraduates
graduate students and medical students
and I've observed that
when I'm teaching I have to stop
speaking if I'm going to write something
on the board I just have to stop all
speaking completely right it turns out
this is an advantage to catch because it
allows me to catch my voice it allows me
to slow down a bit you know breathe and
inhale some oxygen and so on because I
tend to speak quickly if I'm not writing
something out so there's a break in this
circuitry for me or at least they are
distinct enough that I have to stop and
then write something yes that that that
that that does imply competing brain
circuits for your conscious attention
we have colleagues um up at Columbia Med
who are known at least in our circles
for dictate voice dictating their papers
not writing them out but just speaking
into a voice recorder uh I've written
papers that way it doesn't feel quite as
natural for me as writing things out but
not because I can go quickly from
thought to language to typing I type
reasonably fast I can touch type now I
don't think I ever taught my I think I
taught myself I never took a touch type
of course it just sort of happened now I
think my motor system seems to know
where the keys are with enough uh
enough accuracy that it works
the this is remarkable to me that any of
us can do this but
when it comes to writing what I've found
is that if my rate of thought and my
rate of writing are aligned nicely
things go well and however if I'm
thinking much faster than I can write
that's a problem and certainly if I'm
thinking more slowly than I want to
write that's also a problem and the
solution for me has been to write with a
pen I'm in love with these and I have no
relationship to the company at least not
now although if they want to come you
know if they want to work with us I love
these pilot V5 v7s because not
necessarily because of the ink or the
the feel although I like that as well
but because of the rate that it allows
me to write they write very well slowly
and they write very well quickly and so
I have this Theory
supported only by my own anec data no
peer-reviewed study that
writing by hand is fundamentally
different than typing out information is
there any evidence that this motor
pathway for writing
is better or somehow different than the
motor pathway for for typing yeah that
that's interesting
um and I don't know of any studies I
have my own personal experience as well
but trying to put this into the context
if I had to you know design an
experiment to test the hypothesis here
that you know to explain your experience
in mind is that writing by hand i'm I
would argue
requires a different set of less skills
with the fingers
than typing so you have you have to
coordinate your fingers more in opposite
directions and so forth of a typing but
also writing by hand requires more arm
movement uh and so therefore I would
argue that the
um the the difficulty there could be in
the types of muscles and the fine motor
control you need of those muscles along
with speaking in your brain at the same
time so basically I'm a coarse I'm a
brute and so it makes sense that I would
a more primitive writing device would
work that's right yes but but let me let
me add to this in terms of the
um I my own personal experience right
what I find is
I can write I can write something Faster
by hand
um for a short period of time compared
to typing and that is because I think I
I run out of the energy in my arm
movements uh faster than I run out of
muscle energy in my finger movements uh
and I think it takes a longer time for
us to write words with our fingers uh
because and in terms of the speech so I
think your writing whether it's by hand
or typing into your speech it only will
align very well if you can type as fast
as you can speak or write as fast as you
can speak in your head I love it so what
you've done if I understand correctly is
created a bridge between thought and
writing and that bridge is speech that
bridge is speech that's right that's
right when you're writing something out
you're speaking it to yourself and if
you're speaking faster than you can type
you got a problem
interesting I uh I do a number of
podcast episodes that are not with
guests but solo episodes and as
listeners know these are very long
episodes often two or more hours and
um we joke around the podcast Studio
that I I will get locked into a mode of
speech where some of it is more
elaborative and
um anecdotal and then I'll and then I'll
punch out
um simple declarative sentences I find
it very hard to switch from one module
to the next the thing that I have done
in order to
um make that transition more fluid and
prep for those podcast episodes is
actually to read the lyrics of songs and
to sing them in my head
as a way of warming up my vocal cords
but um luckily for those around me uh
when I do that I'm not actually singing
out loud and so this uh what you're
telling me
um supports this idea that even when we
are imagining
singing or writing in our mind we are
exercising our vocal cords you're
actually getting a little low potentials
of electrical currents reaching your
muscles there which also means you're
exercising your speed sprain circuits
too without actually you know going with
the flowable activity in the muscles
incredible yes and this this idea of
singing helps you as well uh
um even with Parkinson's patients and so
forth when they want to say something
singing or listening to music helps them
move better and the idea there is that
the brain circuits for singing or let's
say the function of the brain circuits
for speech being used for singing first
is the more ancestral trait and that's
why it's easier to do things with
singing sometimes than it is with
speaking I love it
stutter is a particularly interesting
case and and one that every once in a
while I I'll get questions about this
from our audience um
stutter is is complicated in in a number
of ways but culturally
um in my understanding from these emails
that I receive is that um stutter can
often cause people to hide and speak
less because it can be embarrassing and
we're we are often not patient with with
stutter we also have the assumption that
if somebody's stuttering that they're
thinking is slow but it turns out there
are many examples historically of people
who could not speak well but who were
brilliant thinkers
um I don't know how well they could
write but they found other modes of
communication uh I realize that you're
not a speech pathologist or therapist
but what is the current neurobiological
understanding of stutter and are what's
being developed in terms of treatments
for stutter yeah so we actually uh
accidentally came across stuttering in
songbirds and we've published several
papers on this to try to figure out the
neurobiological basis the first study we
had was a brain area
called the basal ganglio this with the
the strainum part of the basal ganglia
involved in coordinating movements
learning how to make movements when it
was damaged in these in this in a
speech-like pathway in these birds
what we've found is that they started to
stutter as the brain region recovered
and unlike humans they actually
recovered after three or four months and
why is that the case because bird brains
undergoes new neurogenesis in a way that
human or mammal brains don't and it was
the new neurons that were coming in into
the circuit but not quite you know with
the right proper activity was resulting
in this stuttering in these birds and
after it was repaired not exactly the
old song came back as a after the repair
but still it recovered a lot better and
it's now known they call this neurogen
neurogenics of stuttering in humans
would bet damage to the Brazil ganglia
or some type of disruption to the basal
ganglia at a young age also causes
stuttering in humans and even those who
were born with stuttering uh um it's
often the basal ganglia that's disrupted
than some other brain circuit and we
think the speech part of of the basal
ganglia can adults who maintain a
Stutter from childhood repair that
stutter they can repair it with a
therapy with learning how to speak
slower or learning how to tap out a
rhythm during that and yeah I'm not a
speech pathologist but I started reading
this literature and talking to others at
you know colleagues who actually study
study stuttering so yes there there are
ways to overcome the stuttering through
um through uh you know behavioral
therapy uh and I think all of the tools
out there
has something to do with sensory motor
integration uh controlling what you hear
with what you output in a of thoughtful
controlled way helps reduce the
stuttering there are a couple examples
from real life that I want to touch on
and um one is somewhat facetious but
um but now I realize is a serious
neurobiological issue serious meaning I
think interesting which is that every
once in a while I will have a
conversation with somebody who says the
last word of the sentence along with me
and it seems annoying in some instances
uh but I'm guessing this is just a
breakthrough of the motor pattern that
they're hearing what I'm saying very
well so I'm going to interpret this it
kindly and think they're hearing what
I'm saying they're literally hearing it
in their mind and they're getting that
low level electrical activity to their
throat and they're just joining me in
the uh in the enunciation of what I'm
saying probably without realizing it can
we assume that that might be the case
well I I wouldn't be surprised so that
you know the motor theory of speech
perception where this idea originally
came what you hear is going through your
speech circuit and then also activating
those muscles slightly uh so yes
um so one might argue
okay is that speech circuit now
interpreting what that person is
speaking now you're listening to me and
is going to finish it off because it's
already going through their brain and
they can predict it that would be one
one Theory I don't think the verdict out
there is no but that's one the other is
uh synchronizing turn taking in in the
con the conversation where you're
acknowledging that we understand each
other by finishing off what I say uh and
it's almost like a social bonding kind
of thing the other could be I want the
person to shut out so I can speak as
well and take that turn and and each
pair of people have a rhythm to their
conversation and if you have somebody
who's over talkative versus Under
talkative or vice versa that Rhythm can
be lost in them finishing ideas and
going back and forth but I I think
having something to do with turn taking
as well makes a lot of sense I have a
colleague at Stanford who says that
Interruption is a sign of interest I'm
not sure that everyone agrees I think
it's highly contextual yes but there is
this form of of a verbal nod I was
saying or things of that sort and there
are many of these uh and I'm often told
by my audience you know that I'd
interrupt my guests and things of that
sort oftentimes I'll just get caught in
the natural flow of the conversation uh
but well I I think we've had pretty good
turn taking here I hope that's so far so
good I feel that way I'm glad you feel
that way because especially in the
context of a discussion about language
yes it seems important
um
texting is a very very interesting
evolution of language because
what you've told us is that we have a
thought it's translated into language it
might not be complete sentences but
texting I have to imagine this is the
first time in human evolution where
we've written with our thumbs so I don't
you know it seems more primitive to me
than typing with fingers or writing
hands but hey who Am who am I to judge
the evolution of our species in One
Direction or the other but the shorthand
grammatically often grammatically
deficient incomplete sentence form of
texting is an incredible thing to see
um early in relationships romantic
relationships people will often evaluate
the other's text and their ability to
use proper grammar and spelling Etc this
often quickly degrades and there's an
acceptance that we're just trying to
communicate through shorthand almost
um
military likes shorthand but with
internally consistent between people but
there's no General consensus of what
things mean but you know
wtfs and like in OMGs and all sorts of
things
I wonder sometimes whether or not we are
getting less proficient at speech
because we are not required to write and
think in complete sentences
I'm not being judgmental here I see this
in my colleagues I see this in myself
this is not a judgment of the younger
generation
um I also know that slang has existed
for decades if not hundreds of years but
I also know that I don't speak the same
way that I did when I was a teenager
because I've suppressed a lot of that
slang not because it's inappropriate or
offensive although some of it was
frankly
um but because it's out of context so
what do you think is happening to
language are we getting better at
speaking worse at speaking and what do
you think the role of things like
texting and tweeting and shorthand
communication hashtagging what's that
doing to the way that our brains work
yeah I I think that um a one in terms of
you know uh measuring your level of
sophistication intelligence and you say
OMG right I think that also could be a
cultural thing that ah you belong to the
Next Generation if you're you know or
you're being cold if you're an older
person you know using OMG and other
things that the the you know younger
generation would use
but uh really think about it clearly
um
uh texting actually has allowed for more
rapid communication amongst people I I
think with without the invention of the
phone before then or you know uh texting
back and forth you had to wait days for
a letter to show up you couldn't call
somebody on the phone and talk as well
you know and so this rapid communication
well in terms of the rapid communication
of writing in this case
um so I think actually
it's it's more like a use it or lose it
kind of a
um uh thing with the brain the more you
use a particular brain region or circuit
the more enhanced it's like a muscle uh
the more you exercise it the more
healthier it is the bigger it becomes
and the more space it takes and the more
you you lose something else so I think
taxing I my is not decreasing uh the the
the speech prowess or the intellectual
prowess of speech it's converting it and
using it a lot in a different way uh in
a way that may not be as rich in in
regular writing because uh you can only
communicate so much Nuance in short term
writing but um whatever that it whatever
is being done you got people texting
hours and hours and hours on the phone
so whatever your thumb circuit is going
to get pretty big actually
I do wonder whether you know many people
have lost their jobs based on tweets
the short latency between thought and
action and distribution of one's
thoughts is is incredible yes and I'm
not just talking about people who have
um who apparently would have poor
prefrontal top-down control this is geek
speak by the way for people that lack
impulse control but high level academics
I'm not going to point fingers at anyone
but examples of in where you see these
tweets what were they thinking yep uh so
presumably there's an optimal uh
strategy between the the thought speech
motor motor pathway especially when the
motor pathway engages communication with
hundreds of thousands of people and
retweets in particular in the cut and
paste function and the screenshot
function are often the reason why speech
propagates yep so to me it's it's a
little Eerie that
um that just that the neural circuitry
can do this and that we are catching up
a little bit more slowly to the
technology and you've got these
casualties of of the that mismatch I I
think that's a good
um adjectives we use the casualties you
know of what's going on because yes it
is the case with texting what you're
really losing their is not less so the
ability to write but more the ability to
interpret what is being written and you
can over underturp it something that
somebody means
on the flip side of that you know when
if somebody's writing something very
quick
uh they could be writing instinctually
more instinctually their true meaning
and they don't have time to modify and
color code what they're trying to say
and that's what they really feel uh and
as opposed to say in a more nuanced way
so I think both sides of that casualty
are are present uh and that's a downturn
you know an unintended uh negative
consequence of uh short commit term I
mean short word communication yeah I
agree that
um this whole phenomenon could be
netting people that normally would only
say these things out loud once inside
the door of their own home or not at all
right it's a it's an interesting time
that we're in he's a speech and language
and motor patterns so part of the human
evolution for language I I think this is
all part of our Evolution that's right
so for those of you thinking terrible
thoughts please put them in the world
and be a casualty and for those of you
that are not please be very careful with
how proficient your thought to language
to motor action yes it goes maybe the
technology companies should install some
buffers some AI based buffers right
that's taking some EG signals from your
brain while you're texting to say okay
this this is uh you know this is not a
great thought slow down right this
doesn't reflect your best state
that brings me to the what was going to
be the next question anyway which is we
are quickly moving toward a time where
there will be an even faster transition
from thought to speech to motor output
and maybe won't require motor out but
what I'm referring to here is some of
the incredible work of our colleagues
Eddie Chang at UCSF and others who are
taking
um paralyzed human beings and learning
to translate the electrical signals of
neurons in various areas including
speech and language areas to computer
screens that type out what these people
are thinking in other words paralyzed
people can put their thoughts on in into
writing that's a pretty extreme and
wonderful example of recovery of
function that is sure to continue to
evolve
but I think we are headed toward a time
not too long from now where
my thoughts can be translated into words
on a page if I allow that to happen yeah
so and Eddie Chang's work which I admire
quite a bit in citing my papers uh I
think he's really one of those at the
Leading Edge of trying to understand
within humans uh the the neurobiology of
speech and he may not say it directly
but I you know I talked to him about
this it supports this idea that the
speech circuit and the separate language
module I don't really uh think that
there's a separation there so with with
that knowledge yes and putting
electrodes in the human brain and then
translating those electrical signals to
speech uh currents yeah we can start to
tell what is that person thinking why
because we often think in terms of
speech uh and um without saying words
and that's a scary thought and now
imagine if you can now translate those
into a signal that transmits something
wirelessly and someone from some distant
part of the planet is hearing your
speech from a wireless signal uh without
you speaking uh so
probably that won't be done in an
ethical way who knows you know but the I
mean the ethics of doing that probably
you know might not happen but who knows
we have these songbirds you know we
applied the same technique to them we
can start to hear what they're singing
in their dreams or whatever even though
they don't produce sound so we can find
out by testing on them it's coming one
way or another it's coming
for those listening who are interested
in getting better at speaking and
understanding languages are there any
tools that you recommend and here again
I let I realize you're not a speech
therapist but here I'm not thinking
about ameliorating any kind of
um speech deficiency I'm thinking for
instance do you recommend that people
read different types of writing
um would you recommend that people learn
how to dance in order to become better
at expressing themselves verbally
um you know and feel free to have some
some degrees of freedom in in this
answer this these are obviously not uh
peer-reviewed studies that we're
referring to although there may be
um but I'm struck by the number of
things that you do exceedingly well and
I can't help but ask
um well the the singing which I realize
it may your brother didn't pay me to say
this might not be quite as good as your
brothers yet but is getting you'll
surpass them I'm guessing at some point
nice exactly there you go
um you know
should kids learn how to dance and read
hard books and simple books what do you
recommend should adults learn how to do
that too everyone wants to know how to
keep their brain working better so to
speak but also I think people want to be
able to speak well and people want to be
able to understand well yeah so what
I've discovered personally right is that
so when I switch from
pursuing a career in science from a
career in dance
um I thought one day I would stop
dancing
um but I haven't because it I find it
fulfilling for me
um you know just as a life experience so
ever since I started college you know my
late teens and early 20s I I kept
dancing even till this day and there
have been periods of time like during
the pandemic where I slowed down on
dancing and so forth
um and and when you do that you realize
okay they're they're parts of your body
where your muscle tone decreases a
little bit and somewhat and or you could
start to gain weight or I somehow don't
gain weight that easily and I think it's
related to my dance if that's that
that's meaningful to your audience
um but what I found is you know in in in
science we like to think of a separation
between movement and action and
cognition and there is a separation for
you between between perception and
production cognition being perception
production being movement right but if
the speech Pathways is next to movement
Pathways what I discover is by dancing
it is helping me
think it is helping keeping my brain
fresh it's not just moving my muscles
I'm moving or using the the circuitry in
my brain to do control a whole big body
you need a lot of brain tissue to do
that and so I argue if you want to stay
cognitively intact into your old age you
better be moving and you better be doing
it consistently whether it's dancing
walking running and also practicing
speech
oratory speech and so forth or singing
is controlling the brain circuits that
are moving your facial musculature and
it's going to keep your cognitive
circuits also in tune and I'm I'm
convinced of that from my own personal
experience now for me uh long slow runs
are a wonderful way to kind of loosen
the joints for long podcasts especially
the solo podcast which can take many
hours to record and without those long
slow runs at least the day before or
even the morning of I don't think I
could do it at least not as well all
right well you're you're experiencing
something similar so that's an N of two
yeah no two uh I'm I'm tempted to learn
how to dance because uh there are a lot
of reasons to learn how to dance people
can use their imagination
I definitely want to get the opportunity
to talk about some of the newer work
that you're into right now uh about
genomes of animals
um as you perhaps can tell from my quite
authentic facial expressions I I Adore
the animal kingdom I just find it
amazing and it's the reason I went into
neurobiology in part
um so many animals so many different
patterns of movement so many body plans
so many specializations
what is the value of learning the
genomes of all these animals it you know
I can think of
conservation based you know schemes of
trying to preserve these precious uh
Critters
um but what are you doing with the
genomes of these animals what do you
want to understand about their brain
circuits and how does this relate to
some of the discussion we've been having
up until yeah I I've gotten very heavily
involved in genomes
um you know not just to get at an
individual Gene involved in the trait of
Interest like spoken language
um but I realized that you know Nature
has done natural experiments for us
um but all these species out there with
these various traits and the one that
I'm studying like vocal learning has
evolved multiple times among the animal
kingdom even if it's rare it's multiple
times
and
uh the similar genetic changes occurred
in those species but to find out what
those genetic changes that are
associated with the trait of interest
and not some other trait like flying in
birds as opposed to singing
um you have to do what's called
comparative genomics even in the context
of studying the brain and you need their
genomes to compare the genomes and do
like a g was a genome-wide Association
study not just within a species like
humans but across species and so you
need a good genomes to do that
plus I've discovered I'm also interested
in evolution and Origins how did these
species come about a similar trait and
uh in in last you know 300 million years
or 60 million years depending who you're
talking about uh and you need a good
phylogenetic tree to do that and to get
a good phylogenetic tree you also need
their genomes
and so because of this I got involved in
large-scale consortiums to produce
genomes of many different species
including my vocal Learners and my their
closest relatives that I'm fans of but I
couldn't convince the funding agencies
to give me the money to to do that just
for my own project but when you get a
whole bunch of people together who want
to study various traits you know heart
disease or what or loss and gain of
flight and so forth suddenly we all need
lots of genomes to do this and so now
that got me into a project to lead
something called the vertebrate genomes
project to eventually sequence all 70
000 species on the planet and Earth bio
Genome Project all eukaryotic species
all two million of them uh and and to no
longer
be in a situation where I wish I had
this genome now we have the genetic code
of all life on the planet create a
database of all their traits and find
the genetic association with everything
uh out there that makes a difference
from one species to another
uh one more piece of uh of the equation
to add to this story
is what I didn't realize as a
neuroscientist were that these genomes
are not only incomplete but there have
lots of errors in them
false Gene duplications where mother and
father chromosomes were so different
from each other that the genome
algorithm assembly algorithms treated
them as two different genes in this part
of the chromosome
so there are a lot of these false
duplicated genes that people were
thought were real but were not or
missing parts of the genome because the
enzymes used to sequence the DNA
couldn't get through this regulatory
region that folded up on itself and made
it hard to sequence and so I end up in
in these consortiums uh pulling in the
genome sequencing companies developing
the technology to work with us to
improve it further in the computer
science guys who then take that data and
that technology and try to make the
complete genomes and make the algorithms
better to produce what we now just did
recently and led by an effort by ad in
Philippi is the first human Tel American
t lamborghiniome with no errors all
complete no missing sequence and now
we're trying to do the same thing with
vertebrates and other species actually
we improved that but even before we got
to the what we call Tel emerto telomere
from one end of the chromosome some to
another and what we're discovering
is in this dark matter of the genome
that was missing before turns out to be
some regulatory regions that are
specialized in vocal learning species
and we think are involved in developing
speech circuits incredible well so much
to learn and that we're going to learn
from this information early on in these
genome projects and connect Dome
projects I confess I was a little bit
cynical this would be about 10 15 years
ago I I thought okay necessary but not
sufficient for anything we need it but
it's not clear what's going to happen
but you just gave a very clear example
of what we stand to learn from this kind
of information and
um and I know from the conservation side
there's a huge interest in this because
even though we would prefer to keep all
these species alive rather than clone
them they're these sorts of projects do
offer the possibility of potentially
recreating species that were lost right
due to our own ignorance or
um missteps or what have you yes and and
along those lines
uh because you know we got involved in
genomics some of the first species that
we start working on are critically
endangered species and I'm doing that
not only for uh
for under you know perspectives to
understand their brains and the genes
involved in their brain function but I
feel like it's a moral duty so the fact
that now I become more involved in
genome biology and have helped develop
these tools for more complete genomes
let's capture their their genetic code
now before they're gone uh and could we
use that information uh to resurrect the
species at some future time if not in my
lifetime in some time in the future and
generations ahead of us
and so um in do in anticipation of that
we create a database we call the genome
Mark uh and and no pun intended like
Noah's Ark meant to store the genetic
code AS complete genome assemblies as
possible for all species on the planet
uh to be used for basic science but also
some point in the future uh and because
of that uh funding agencies or private
foundations that are interested in
conservation have been reaching out to
me now a neuroscientist uh to help them
out in producing high quality genome
data of endangered species that they can
use like revive and restore who want to
resurrect the passenger pigeon or
colossal who wants to resurrect the
woolly mammoth and so we're producing
high quality genomes for these groups
for the conservation projects what a
terrific and important initiative and I
think for those listening today they now
certainly understand the value of under
of deeply understanding the brain
structures and genomes of different
species because I confess even though I
knew that a bit of the Songbird
literature and I certainly understand
that humans have speech and language I
had no idea that there was so much
convergence of function structure and
genomes and to me you know I feel a lot
more like a an ape than I do a songbird
right and yet here we are with the
understanding that there's a lot more
similarity between songbirds and humans
than I certainly ever thought before
yeah something very close to home for us
humans I can give you an example of is
evolution of skin color uh in skin color
we use it unfortunately for racism and
so forth we use it also for good things
to let in more light or let out less
light depending on the part of the
planet you know our population evolved
in and most people think dark-skinned
people all evolve from the same
dark-skinned person and light-skinned
people all evolve in the same light skin
person but that's not the case
dark skin and light skin amongst humans
has evolved independently multiple times
like in you know the Pacific Islands
versus Africa and it and it it's just
depending on the angle of light hitting
the Earth as to whether you need more
protection from the Sun or less
protection uh to that's also associated
with vitamin D sentences uh in the skin
and so um and each time
um uh where a darker or lighter skin
evolved independently it hit the same
gene you know um you know the Melatonin
um melanin melanin receptors that's
right yes yeah genes that are involved
in melanin formation uh and so um those
genes evolve some of the same mutations
even in different species it's not just
humans uh in Equatorial regions there
are darker skinned animals than going
away from the equator all right I think
of arctic foxes that's right that's
right polar bears you know and so uh and
so some of the same genes are used in in
an evolutionary perspective to evolve in
a similar way within and across species
incredible yeah and that's same thing
happening in the brain too language is
no exception well I have to say as
somebody who is a you know career
neuroscientist but as I mentioned
several times that who also adores the
animal kingdom but it's
also obsessed with speech and language
and um at a distance not as a as a
practitioner of of music and dance this
has been an incredible conversation and
opportunity for me to learn and I know I
speak for a tremendous number of people
when I I just really want to say thank
you for joining us today you are
incredibly busy it's clear from your
description of your science and your
knowledge base that you are involved in
a huge number of things
um very busy so thank you for taking the
time to speak to all of us
thank you for the work that you're doing
both on speech and language but also
this important work on genomes and
conservation of endangered species and
far more and I have to say uh if you
would agree to come back and speak to us
again sometime I'm certain that if we
were to sit down even six months or a
year from now there's gonna be a lot
more to come yeah we have some things
cooking and uh and thank you for
inviting me here to get the word out to
the community uh of what's going on in
the Science World we're honored and very
grateful to Eric thank you you're
welcome thank you for joining me today
for my discussion with Dr Eric Jarvis if
you'd like to learn more about his
laboratory's work you can go to Jarvis
lab spell
j-a-r-v-i-s lab all one word
jarvislab.net and there you can learn
about all the various studies taking
place in his laboratory as well as some
of the larger overarching themes that
are driving those studies including
studies on human genomics and animal
genomics that surely are going to lead
to the next stage discoveries of how
learn and think about and indeed use
language if you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast please subscribe
to our YouTube channel that's a simple
zero cost way to support us please also
subscribe to the podcast on Spotify and
apple and on both Spotify and apple you
have the opportunity to leave us up to a
five star review
if you have questions or comments or
suggestions about topics you'd like us
to cover guess you'd like us to
interview on The huberman Lab podcast
please put those in the comments section
on YouTube we do read all those comments
and we do take them to heart please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning of today's podcast and check
out momentousupplements our new partners
in the supplement space and check out
athletic greens that's the best way to
support this podcast if you're not
already following us on social media
please do so we are huberman lab on
Twitter and we are also huberman lab on
Instagram and both places I cover
science and science related tools some
of which overlap with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is unique from the content covered on
the huberman Lab podcast again that's
huberman lab on Instagram and huberman
lab on Twitter please also check out our
neural network monthly newsletter this
is a newsletter that has summaries of
podcast episodes it also includes a lot
of actionable protocols it's very easy
to sign up for the newsletter you go to
hubermanlab.com click on the menu go to
newsletter you supply your email but we
do not share your email with anybody we
have a very clear and rigorous privacy
policy which is we do not share your
email with anybody and the newsletter
comes out once a month and it is
completely zero cost again just go to
hubermanlab.com and go to the neural
network newsletter I'd also like to
point out that the huberman Lab podcast
has a Clips channel so these are brief
Clips anywhere from three to ten minutes
that Encompass single Concepts and
actionable protocols related to sleep to
focus interviews with various guests we
talk about things like caffeine when to
drink caffeine relative to sleep alcohol
when and how and if anyone should ingest
it relative to sleep
dopamine serotonin mental health
physical health and on and on all the
things that relate to the topics most of
interest to you you can find that easily
by going to YouTube look for huberman
lab Clips in the search area they will
take you there subscribe and we are
constantly updating those with new clips
this is especially useful I believe for
people that have missed some of the
earlier episodes or you're still working
through the back catalog of huberman Lab
podcast which admittedly can be rather
long and last but certainly not least
thank you for your interest in science
[Music]